hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast integrated interrogation
of oncogenic signaling pathways
immunology and heterogeneity in cancer
presented by Michael Davis and Joseph
Beecham dr. Michael Davis is the deputy
chairman and associate professor in the
Department of melanoma medical oncology
at the University of Texas MD Anderson
Cancer Center dr. Joseph btrim is senior
vice president of research and
development at nano Strang technology I
am Margaret aureus of Lavery's and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by nano stirring
technologies for more information about
our sponsor please visit WWE begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen
what answer has many questions we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom or
center of your screen or use the ask the
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
accreditation button located in the
promotional board at the bottom or
center of your screen and follow the
process to obtain your credit restore me
in welcoming dr. Michael Davis and dr.
Joseph Beecham I will now turn the
presentation over to them
thank you very much that's Joe Beecham I
lead R&D for Nana sting and I'll be
introducing you to a brand new platform
that we've recently developed called the
digital spatial profiler I'll give you
some background on how we develop the
microscope and then I will hand it over
to Mike and he's going to describe you
exciting new things that are actually
happening on this microscope in the area
of cancer immuno oncology so just as a
brief introduction to Nana stiring
technologies we develop methodologies
that allow you to perform assays on
proteins
Klingon the goodbye very interesting
expression gene fusions copy numbers
single cell gene expression as well as
micro rna's our technology is
highlighted by being able to analyze up
to 800 targets at a time so it's a
multiplex assay that measures 800
different things and a little snapshot
of the view of the current instruments
these are not the brand-new microscopes
were we talking about our current
instruments that run these assays are
shown there in the in the upper left
portion of the screen that one there
you're looking at it's actually called
the Mac let me describe to you a little
bit about the background on mastering
and how we actually make measurements we
make measurements something that's
called single molecule optical barcode
counting and it sounds like a mouthful
but it's relatively straightforward to
understand what you can see on the
screen is a whole series of things look
like balls actually six of them there
and they each ball can be one of four
colors and there's a key to an in a
string and that's then a string in our
name is that the pattern of colors
represents the actual analyte of
interest that you're going to be
measuring so it's gonna be an automated
microscope it reads that barcode and it
determines the digital council
associated with either mRNAs or proteins
so by just changing the color positions
of those balls on the end of that
particular you can see that small piece
of 50 base pair of nucleotide overhang
you can index into up to 800 different
things so then when we make our
measurements our technologies is
amplification free it is single molecule
direct digital counting of the analytes
of interest so the nature of our data
it's all completely digital and it's
highlighted because by not using enzymes
or amplification so we want to measure
something we actually generate
hybridization complexes that actually
will take these particularly agents that
are designed to measure up to one of
eight hundred different targets and when
those reagents that we make here
combined with the nucleic acid and you
can see that they're in the middle of a
stream of nucleic acid comes in it
hybridizes with both sort of the 50 end
of the optical barcode which you can see
to the right and a little white ball on
the left hand side of the screen is
actually a biotin molecule so we mix
these samples together the measure
nucleic acid that came out of the cell
of interest or the tissue of interest
forms a hybridization complex it
combines with the single molecule
optical barcode that allows us to see a
single molecule and then we digitally
count that and that is the nature of the
intrinsic nature of our detection
chemistry now
these barcodes that we've developed and
this is an important work that we
actually did a long collaboration with
MD Anderson where microphone on this
webinar also came from is that we
actually advanced this barcode
technology so we not only measure RNA
expression we can also measure single
nucleotide variants in DNA and we also
can measure protein a single molecule
counting also you can see for the little
trick we did the measure proteins
digitally since they obviously do not
have nucleic acids is that we actually
take antibodies label them with a
smallest system or single stranded piece
of DNA and then we allow we count the
single antibody through the
hybridization complex on the tail of the
antibody so that's how we we do the
protein based detection
now one of the one of the areas that
motivated us to develop this hi clex
microscope because it's wonderful to
measure 800 analytes in solution and
determine the you know the properties of
the tissue under investigation but one
of the key aspects of tissue is actually
the tissue structure itself so instead
of doing sort of grind and bind assays
we just scrape off the tissue slice and
you measure 800 analyte so it's very
very useful thing and it's worked very
well for us there are certain problems
in biology that you actually need to
maintain the tissue structure now the
trouble is when you want to maintain
system structure and I see a tissue you
go into a microscope now the problem is
is when you go into a microscope you're
typically instead of measuring these
beautiful 800 different analytes at a
time I'm sort of stuck with only
measuring roughly one before and the
lights at a time so that was not very
satisfactory for me or Mike he has all
sorts of questions and you know he needs
to look at more than four pieces of
information at a time so we actually
invented a microscope that was designed
intrinsically to be a high Plex
microscope with spatially resolved
capability and this is the design
strategy we use
build a microscope that's totally
different than anything else that is out
there everyone else is trying to put all
the assays components into the tissue
and observe it in the tissue and the
microscope at the same time that's what
limits these assays to roughly four
different colors that you can observe at
any given time we took a totally
different approach so what we did is
that instead of our imaging reagents or
instead of our reagents that are
actually our affinity reagents that are
going to go in there and measure mRNAs
and proteins in a tissue spatially
resolved instead of putting the colors
on our reagents themselves which were
limited alike or we actually did it a
different way all of the measurement
analytes that we have in this new
microscope that we built are actually on
either antibodies or on the fish probes
and you can see that in the lower
left-hand side of this slide and there
on those affinity reagents with a
special kind of linker called a photo
cleavable linker now what this allows us
to do is that we can go ahead and take a
single slide and pour as many as up to
800 antibodies or probe as many as 800
different mRNAs and we can put those
affinity reagents on the tissue sites
itself and then when we go to read them
out instead of actually trying to read
the detection with colors on the inside
we move the microscope objective over
the region that we want to examine
inside the tissue slice that's called a
region of interest when we find that
region of interest we do a brief burst
of 365 nanometer light just on for the
order of about 200 milliseconds
and what that does that releases the
photo cleave the oligonucleotide tags
from these are the backs of the
antibodies or from the MRNA probes that
are in there those photo cleat and you
can see that right in the middle screen
you can see the photo cleat eligos
escaping from the tissue surface and
then as they escape from the tissue
surface with the microscope is designed
to literally drink them with a micro
capillary right off the tissue surface
onto a microtiter plate that is on the
automated microscope
what this allows you to do is you're
making what I call a digital replica of
either the antibody distribution of any
region in space or a digital replica of
the mRNA in a region of space and that's
highlighted by the right side of the
panel you can see those small circles
and things those are regions of interest
on a particular tumor site that we're
investigating and then we with a
microscope objective would have gone
underneath one of those little regions
of interest shine light the barcodes
will come off the surface we digitally
count them one at a time and you end up
with a heat map of digital counts linked
to each one of these individual regions
of interest and that is the and in this
particular manner the microscope can
digitally count single molecules at a
time with up to eight hundred different
analyte classes all in a small region of
interest of the of the tissue surface
and the regions of interest can get very
small all the way down to a single cell
so when you actually perform such an
experiment you can see here in this
particular case we have an excisional
biopsy so it's a tumor biopsy here and
you got highlighted in colors actually
two items what you see in purple are
actually the tumor cells that are lit up
and then the area that you see in green
is actually cd45 this is like the immune
infiltrate that's coming in is starting
to penetrate this particular tumor of
interest now what you can do is a
typical microscope you would just be
limited to these kinds of colors but now
we want to go in and you can see here
let's just take a look at that region
number 10 there with that little small
white circle when I'm in the tumor
region I shine a brief burst of light
and then count the antibodies that are
located in that tumor specific area and
then I count them so that you can see
that when I'm in the tumor itself
markers that are high in tumor but low
in immune cells show up so you can see
the large spike and pan cytokeratin you
see that large purple ball to the right
and that number is very high when I'm in
the tumor environment so when I'm in the
purple area in shine my light but if I
move the microscope book objective over
the region of interest 7 which is now in
the immune infiltrate region and perform
the same experiment and I look at what
antibodies are in that region you can
see there's almost no pen cytokeratin
over there because most of the tumor is
not actually in that region of interest
but what you get is an increase in all
the key immune cell markers that are
localized in that particular area of the
immune infiltrate so this is just sort
of a pictorial display of how these
kinds of experiments were done and
Michael will explain to you exactly the
types of very interesting immuno on
ecology questions you can ask in probe
tissue slices in this manner
so this is the highlight again the
overall flow of the microscope there's
the tumor section on your right you
bathe it with a whole series of
antibodies or mrna fish probes you shine
light and you count
these are the detailed operations that I
showed you schematically and I described
just previously there's your microscope
slide in the center you shine the light
up that would be step number two the
barcodes come off the backs of the
antibodies they're drunk off the surface
of the tissue slice with the micro
capillary that'd be step four those
barcodes are then placed in a microtiter
plate that sits right in the center of
the instrument there you see here left a
digital spatial profiler and then those
photo cleaved oligonucleotides are
dropped into a position a one of a
microtiter plate this entire process
there from Step three four five and six
takes about thirty seconds so then you
actually just select you go back up the
step number two you select a new region
of the tumor that you want to probe and
you repeat so you fill up a microtiter
plate with a digital replica of that the
protein distribution in space on the
tissue surface
now one of the key aspects of this
microscope that's a rather interesting
describe it is a read/write microscope
in the sense that I am writing with
light and wherever I write with light
I'm actually reading all the digital
barcodes that come off the surface at
that particular location so you can do
some very very unique types of
experiments with this configuration and
the writing element is a totally generic
writing element this little thing that
you see labeled number 10 is then called
a digital micromirror device a digital
micromirror vise can shine light in any
specific location and the field of view
of the cell you can see that it's a
colon cancer sample there to your right
and that light that light that I want to
read can be focused all the way down to
a single cell or whole groups of cells
in a very very flexible manner now I'm
going to highlight just one aspect of a
flexible manner of the microscope and I
call it reading and writing in the
language of cancer and this is a unique
ability of this particular microscope
the digital spatial profiler and I'm
going to highlight it here this is a
colon rectal cancer sample here and I'm
staining it with an eye with a dye that
or an antibody that actually is specific
for the tumor cells themselves that's
paying cytokeratin and I'm going to
image that with the microscope in the
color yellow
now a very important answer in question
you want to ask out of of tumors is that
I want to know what the pure signal is
associated with only the tumor cells and
what this allows you to you can see in
that particular colorectal cancer cells
actually about half of the cells you see
in that section the purple ones are
actually immune cells so if I just took
an every signal I would end up with 50%
tumor cell signal 50% that were a mute
of the host immune cell signal and
they're totally convoluted with each
other and I don't actually know what's
the origin of those particular signals
now when I run the microscope though I
can selectively record the pan CK image
and then selectively write with 365
nanometers lights only where the pan ck+
cells are and that is the mask that you
see generated on to the right that mask
goes directly and drives the digital
micromirror device and a single-cell
resolution it will actually shine light
only on the tumor cells and then when I
drink the barcodes after exposing to
light of that particular look looks
complex less there do you see on your
right the black and white when I shine
light like that I know that every
barcode that I'm going to be reading is
actually from the tumor specific cells
without a contamination from the from
the immune cell component that's a very
useful thing so it's like we talked
about that any tumor can be made a
hundred percent cellularity with light
and then I get a pure tumor signal now
just as valuable as I can take that
inverse if I take that mess the tumor
cell insert it now you see that on the
right hand side and right on that same
exact issue slice now what I'll be doing
is collecting only the antibodies that
are in the immune compartment of that
particular tumor slice and then I end up
with a signal that is more 100 percent
related to the immune cells this is a
very unique feature of the microscope so
that in two 30-second operations I end
up with one well with a digital replica
of the tumor only profile and then the
microtiter play well right next to it
could be a hundred percent of the tumor
micro-environment
so I'm going to summarize the overall
intrinsic features of the microscope
here and then I'll hand it over to Mike
and he'll show you what you can actually
do with this on the real clinical
samples so one of the advantages of the
digital spatial profiler the first is
that it highly multiplex so instead of
having one slice of tissue and only
getting four answers now I have one
slice of tissue and you can get up to
800 answers at a time the other aspect
is is the quantization so normally in a
microscope you actually measure
something it's like well how bright
green is it and that's a very hard thing
to quantitate and often times that when
people look at those kinds of images
that will literally do things like put
so that's a three plus signal of how
green that particular area is not a very
quantitative technology but since we are
actually counting single molecule
counting the digital replicas from those
areas the quantity ultimate quantization
this is single molecule counting with up
the six logs of dynamic range so you
don't have to answer well it's it's kind
of bright green plus plus plus you
literally say how how how intense is
that signal when that signal is twenty
three thousand four hundred and twelve
because I counted twenty three thousand
four hundred twelve oligonucleotide
takes from that little region of that
the tissue slice so it's absolutely
quantitative it's single-cell you can
actually focus the digital micromirror
device and actually probe single cells
obviously some markers would be very
difficult to detect it single cells but
not all markers so there's many proteins
that you can observe at the single cell
level one aspect that's also very
interesting I didn't describe it all
during my part of the talk is that's
totally non-destructive the sample has
never been touched by anything other
than light so at the end of the entire
multiplex ASA's we're doing can actually
take that tissue slice out you strip off
the original antibodies that you're
approving it with you store it in a wet
wet medium and it's literally totally
non-destructive you look at the tissue
you can never actually tell it's been
measured you can hand it to anyone else
and they can do any downstream
procedures they wish but often of
interest is that you make a discovery on
that particular slide you're going to
come back and actually reexamine it with
whole new series of analytes a little
different set of antibodies or a
different set of mRNAs you can do that
because it's totally non-destructive
it's a very unique in that manner and
then lastly but also important is that
the throughput of the microscope is in
is in the right kind of speed range we
basically can do 10 to 20 full slides a
day on this microscope and a standard
eight-hour 10-hour workday and this is
the kind of throughput you need if
you're going to interact with someone
like Mike at an MD Anderson where
they're doing clinical trial programs
and these are hundreds of patients often
times that are in these clinical trials
you have to be able to look at a hundred
patients that are patients maybe a
hundred controls and you have to be able
to accomplish that kind of study in a
week something you can't take months to
examine those many tumors so we've
designed it importantly to have that
kind of throughput for a normal sort of
pathology application now I'm going to
hand this back over to Mike and he's
going to describe to you exactly that
very exciting were work that he's doing
in oncology using the digital spatial
profiler so over to you Mike please
thank you very much Joe for that
introduction and I've titled my
presentation today integrated
interrogation of oncogenic signaling
pathways immunology and heterogeneity in
cancer this slide shows my disclosures I
receive research support as the PI for
my institution from several companies
and I've also served on the advisory
board for several companies melanoma is
the most aggressive form of skin cancer
and for decades we really had no
effective therapies for this disease and
very little little understanding of its
pathogenesis and what we've really seen
in the last ten years are really
multiple breakthroughs in the
understanding of the biology of this
disease and interestingly these
breakthroughs have really happened in
parallel in two different areas and so
first we now have a much better
understanding of the molecular drivers
and pathogenesis of melanoma this figure
shows the melanoma TCGA which
demonstrated by whole exome sequencing
that on average melanoma has a higher
mutation burden than any other common
solid tumor and in actual fact in the
majority of these patients we can
actually identify clear oncogenic
drivers that are present in each
patients tumor on the right is
illustrated the fact that we've also
seen multiple breakthroughs in our
understanding of the key regulators of
the anti-tumor immune response in the
same period of time now again as a
researcher we love to see breakthroughs
and understanding but what's been so
rewarding in this field is how this
information has been translated into new
therapies and so really up until 2011
the standard of care for a patient with
metastatic melanoma was enrollment on to
a clinical trial because of the futility
of the existing fda-approved therapies
to start the karbas in chemotherapy
which has a response rate of only 5 to
10% high-dose il-2 a therapy that was
able to cure patients about 5% of the
cases but also a treatment related
mortality rate of 1 to 2% and then
between 2011 and 2016 we saw the
approval of 10 new medications for
patients with stage 4 melanoma all of
which have had significant impact on
overall survival and
interestingly not a single one of these
medications is a chemotherapy instead
they've been divided between targeted
therapies for patients who have a beer a
v600 mutation which is the most common
oncogenic mutations found in this
disease present in about 50% of patients
and we now with our current targeted
therapy combinations of beer F and MEK
inhibitors and patients with b-raf
mutation C response rates of almost 80
percent in disease control rates of
greater than 90 percent and patients on
average respond to these therapies for a
year in parallel we've had the
development of multiple new immune
therapy starting with paluma map in 2011
the approval of single agent pd-1
antibodies parallelism AB and the volume
M in 2014 and then most recently the
ipil uma Magna volume AB combination
these immunotherapies over time have
been observed to be more and more
effective with response rates with
paluma mob of 10% to 40% with pd-1
antibodies to almost 60 percent with the
combinations and impressively the median
duration of the responses with these
immune therapies tends to be quite long
actually difficult to estimate at this
point in time as our data is still
relatively new and so our our field has
really been completely revolutionized
and the treatments that are available in
the outlook for patients and actually as
researchers what's really emerged as the
dominant question now is how do we
actually personalize our therapies how
do we match each patient with the right
treatment and in particular how can we
predict understand and overcome
resistance and so with these questions
there's a tremendous need for new
biomarkers to help us guide and
personalized therapy for patients and as
we've again worked on this area we've
identified a number of key challenges
that need to be addressed first the
concurrent evaluation of molecular and
immune markers again we've had multiple
breakthroughs in the understanding of
molecular biology and in the immunology
of this disease and interestingly what
we're learning is that these two
processes are not separate but actually
closely regulate each other supporting
the rationale for their concurrent
evaluation as I'll describe
secondly we're starting to appreciate
much better the heterogeneity that we
see in molecular de Muniz between
patients between different tumors and
individual patients and even at the
individual tumor level with intramural
heterogeneity and finally as a clinician
one of the ultimate challenges we have
is really again to undertake approaches
that allow us to develop and test
biomarkers using very small clinical
specimens and most commonly
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tissues
and this is again an area we've had
multiple dances over the last few years
and increasing capabilities but we have
to recognize the need potentially for
the ability to look at DNA RNA and or
protein on these small specimens and so
what I'd like to spend the next sort of
15 minutes or so was sort of talking
about some of the research that we've
done in melanoma and how these questions
and challenges are being addressed so as
I mentioned melanoma really has a very
high level of oncogenic mutations and
what we've been able to identify or some
of the key oncogenic pathways that are
activated in this disease and so this
figure shows on the left the grass raft
map kinase signaling pathway on the
right the pi3 kinase Akt pathway so
starting with the map kinase signaling
pathway what we actually know is is that
this is almost a universal event in
melanoma so approximately 50% of
cutaneous melanomas have point mutations
in the B RAF serine threonine kinase
that increase its activity up to 200
fold another 20% of patients have
activating mutations and hen wrasse and
these are mutually exclusive with those
BRF v600 mutations and another 15% of
patients have loss of function mutations
in nf1 and so really between these and a
few other genetic events we know that
activation of the wrath wrath map kinase
signaling pathway is essentially a
universal event that occurs in cutaneous
melanoma now early studies have shown in
melanoma and other cancers that in
wrasse mutations in addition to
activating the map kinase pathway can
activate other pathways and so this was
actually the initial evidence for a role
of the pi3 kinase Akt pathway
in this disease and what we've seen over
time are rare activating mutations in
the pi3 kinase and akt kinases and more
frequently complete loss of expression
of the p10 tumor suppressor gene the
major negative regulator of this pathway
and so overall what we've identified is
that at a significant subset of
cutaneous melanomas have concurrent
activation of the pi3 kinase Akt mTOR
pathway as these events tend to
particularly happen in tumors that have
those activating b-raf mutations we
actually as I mentioned now have
multiple targeted therapies that are
actually approved for patients with a
beer at v600 mutation and again these
therapies can be very effective what's
very interesting though is is that we've
really developed a much better
understanding of the impact of the map
kinase signaling pathway on the
anti-tumor immune response so some of
this work has been led by dr. Jennifer
Wargo who showed first in vitro that in
tumors that have an activating b-raf
mutation that inhibition of the map
kinase pathway resulted in increased
antigen expression on the surface of
melanoma cells making them more
recognisable to the immune system
shortly thereafter Patrick who from MD
Anderson showed in an in vivo model that
blocking the map kinase pathway in a
b-raf mutation in provoking of
therapeutic t-cells into tumors and
again dr. Wargo and also investigators
in Australia have shown in biopsies of
b-raf mutant patients collected before
the start of treatment and after one to
two weeks of treatment that in
metastatic melanoma patients treated
with BRF inhibitors and b raf met
combination that we see with targeted
therapy and upregulation of Malena
SANDAG antigens like mark one is shown
in the very top panel and perhaps just
as critically shown in the lower panel a
massive influx of cd8 positive T cells
into tumors and so this data and
functional studies have now led to
multiple clinical trials that are
ongoing in our field to evaluate the
safety and efficacy of combining
approved immunotherapy with the approved
map kinase pathway targeted therapies
with
really exciting results seen in early
phase clinical trials now as I mentioned
another active pathway in this disease
and a subset of patients is the pi3
kinase Akt pathway which is commonly
activated by loss of the tumor
suppressor p10 and my lab in dr. Patrick
whose lab collaborated to evaluate the
impact of activation of this pathway on
the anti-tumor immune response
our initial in vitro work showed that Co
culturing of tumor cells and immune
cells with that loss of p10 and the
tumor cells made them directly resistant
to t-cell mediated killing and further
in vivo studies in that same model that
they had tested the B ref inhibitor with
showed that when we had loss of p10 in
tumors we identified decreased
infiltration of t-cells into the tumors
in these preclinical models this was
actually really validated in patients by
looking at a large cohort of stage three
melanoma patients as well as the
melanoma TCGA cohort where we found that
tumors that had loss of p10 had less
immune infiltrate so including both cd3
and cd4 positive T cells now t-cell
infiltrates have been strongly linked to
sensitivity to immune checkpoint
inhibitors and particularly anti PD one
and so we reviewed treatment outcomes of
metastatic melanoma patients treated at
our institution with anti pd-1
antibodies this waterfall plot shows the
maximal change in tumor size the bars
that go up I mean the tumors were
growing the bars going down means that
the tumors got smaller the bars that are
blue are reflecting patients who had
intact p10 expression in their tumor and
the bars in red reflect the outcomes of
patients who had complete loss of p10
and as you can see we saw a striking
association with loss of p10 with
inferior responsiveness to anti P d1 and
this resistance to anti PD one was
recapitulated in a gem preclinical model
in which melanomas expressed both the
BRM v600 mutation and have complete loss
of p10 and in this model we saw very
little efficacy with empty PD one anti
ctla-4 or a Knox 40 antibody similarly a
pi/3
kindness betta selectively inhibits
elective inhibitor was able to inhibit
the pi3 kinase pathway in the p10 old
tumour cells without actually
interfering with the immune viability or
function as a single agent it did not
have much activity but when we combined
those two agents together we saw a
market improvement in the t-cell
infiltrate into the tumors and much
better anti-tumor activity and actually
based on this data we now have a phase
one phase two clinical trial ongoing at
MD Anderson combining the pi3 kinase
beta inhibitor with the anti PD one
antibody parallelism AB and p10 no PD
one refractory patients now this slide
actually shows the patterns of p10
expression that we see in melanoma and
particularly in the top left we see an
image of a tumor that has complete loss
of p10 expression in the tumor cells the
only cells that are standing positively
are endothelial cells which act as
really an internal positive control for
a p10 immune history chemistry and we
really see sort of a range of expression
from absent all the way through normal
to increased with roughly a prevalence
of sort of twenty to thirty percent for
each of these patterns and almost all of
our tumors really showed uniformed p10
expression however have we've really
looked at hundreds of stage 3 and stage
4 metastases rarely we've seen tumors
that actually have much more
heterogeneous expression and this is an
example of a tumor that really has areas
that are very distinct with complete
loss of p10 expression on the right side
of this tumor whereas on the left that
area the tumor really expresses very
high levels of the p10 protein and these
rare tumors to us are valuable tools to
really try to better understand the
biology and the immunology associated
with p10 loss so this is data that we
presented at the sit C meeting in 2017
where we went into a handful of these
tumors and first actually did cord
needle biopsies of these heterogeneous
tumors to isolate regions that were p10
expressing or p10 Knowle we isolated DNA
and perform next-generation sequencing a
DNA methylation
we then also isolated RNA from this
tissue for RNA expression profiling an
overall this actually suggested that the
mechanism of p10 loss was most likely
genetic genetic as opposed to epigenetic
and we did see differences in gene
expression patterns however as Joe
mentioned the digital spacial profiling
platform seemed like a really
interesting tool to apply to these
heterogeneous tumors to be able to
actually look broadly at protein
signaling pathways in the anti-tumor
immune response on FFPE slides without
actually sort of going through those
types of defections that we did and also
again the multiplex capability to allow
us to look at multiple different markers
on one to two FFPE slides and so again
on the left is shown sort of the
schemata for how the digital spatial
profiling works for protein profiling
with again the key being these tagged
antibodies with UV sensitive linkers and
so on the right this actually shows an
example of one of these tumors with
heterogeneous p10 expression and so the
panel on the left side is actually the
p10 in monistic chemistry showing the
region of the tumor that had p10 protein
expression shown in brown and labeled as
p10 positive and at the bottom the p10
no area where again we see an absence of
staining and so as Joe mentioned we
selected multiple regions of interest or
ro eyes in the p10 positive and t10 mil
regions those in the p10 positive are
the red circle seen in the upper part of
the slide and the RO is and the p10 mil
region shown down at the bottom in blue
and so we used one slide to evaluate a
panel of immune markers and another
slide to evaluate a panel of signaling
marker signaling pathway markers and so
this is actually shown on the left hand
part of the slide then just our first
initial analysis of the first tumor that
we ran on the digital spatial profiling
platform so again we had six regions of
interest from the p10 positive areas of
this tumor and these are reflected in
the bar graph of the left with the six
bars and then on the right the RO is
from the p10 null region of the tumor
and so as a first validation we're very
interested looking at p10 expression we
actually found that an antibody
recognizing phospho p10 was a
particularly robust marker that
correlated very well with immune histah
chemistry we then started looking at
activation specific molecules such as
phospho a KT and consistent with our
previous studies in frozen tissues we
saw that the regions that had complete
loss of p10 had elevated levels of
phospho a KT although what is also
interesting and again a unique
capability of the digital spacial
profiling platform because we can
actually see there's heterogeneity
within the peatonal region again in the
region that expressed high levels of p10
very low levels of phosphate KT and
again then moving further down the
pathway to the level of phosphorylation
of for a BP 1 again consistently we see
do see high levels of possible for EBP 1
in the P channel regions but now we do
actually see some other areas of the
tumor where p10 is expressed where we do
see high levels of this phosphoprotein
so again I think on a single tumor level
sort of a nice illustration of how we
could actually again look separately at
the p10 null and positive regions and so
we actually did this analysis on 7
tumors that had heterogeneous p10
expression and so again just confirming
they were bust mass of looking at p10
expression we saw again a market
difference in the p10 expression as
analyzed by digital spacial profiling
and we identified several proteins that
were significantly up regulated in the
peatonal region including phospho a
Katie and phospho P 76 K as expected and
we can also see sort of a series of
signaling proteins that were down
regulated or expressed at lower levels
in the p1000 region and again as Jo
explained we could also look at immune
markers and so again similar to what we
had seen in our images to chemistry
studies we saw down regulation of CD 3
CD 5 cd45 and CD 8 in the peatonal
regions of the tumor but also other
interesting markers we hadn't looked at
before such as vista and so again i
think looking at sort of individual
heterogeneous tumors where we again
looking at different molecular
phenotypes sort of a nice sort of proof
of principle study of sort of the
capabilities of the digital spacial
profiling
now another area that we've been very
interested in in terms of molecular
heterogeneity or brain metastasis so
brain metastases are a huge clinical
problem in many diseases but they're a
particular problem in melanoma and
indeed among all solid cancers melanoma
actually has the highest risk of CNS
metastasis with up to 70% of patients
showing evidence of CNS involvement on
autopsy studies historically these
patients have had very poor outcomes
with a median overall survival of
approximately four months from diagnosis
and those outcomes are improving with
our contemporary targeted therapies and
immune therapies however we're
consistently seeing that those
treatments do not work as well in
patients with brain metastases and in
the brain metastases themselves as we
see in extracranial tumors and indeed
the brain is a common initial site of
relapse for both targeted enemy in
therapies and while historically much of
the challenge of brain metastases has
sort of been attributed to the
difficulty of penetrating the
blood-brain barrier there really is very
strong evidence now that brain
metastasis significantly disrupt the
blood-brain barrier and that there's
significant leakage of drugs into that
space indeed the BRF inhibitor dubrovnik
which was not predicted to cross the
blood-brain barrier based on preclinical
studies has actually very high response
rates in melanoma patients with brain
metastases and what's really instead
growing is an increasing appreciation
supported by data from multiple groups
showing that there can be unique
molecular and immune features in brain
metastases compared to non CNS
metastases and we've done some work in
this area our initial study back in 2009
was an experiment in which we looked at
Oct embedded or frozen melanoma
metastasis we had looked largely at
regional metastasis but we also did a
pilot study of small cohorts of distant
metastases receptive from the brain the
liver and the lung we used HD guided
macro dissection to isolate tumor
enriched regions and then did protein
isolation which we then ran on the
reverse phase protein array platform and
Dee Anderson and as an again an initial
hypothesis we're very interesting and
looking at the correlates of pi3 kinase
pathway activation and so this graph
shows the data for three different
activation specific markers in the pi3
kinase pathway the blue bar showed the
levels of phospho akp serine 473 the red
bars phospho 883 and 308 and the yellow
bars phosphorylated GSK 3 alpha beta the
green bars again show the levels of
expression of the negative regulator of
this pathway p10 and the data shows the
median value for multiple tumors
isolated from each of these sites and
although this was again a pilot study a
relatively small number of tumors we saw
a striking up regulation of activation
specific markers in the pi3 kinase
pathway in the brain metastasis compared
to liver and lung metastasis and also
significantly lower expression of p10 in
the brain metastasis now these tumors
were from different patients and so we
did a subsequent study and actually we
went back to our our tumor Bank and
identified brain metastasis that had
been resected from patients with
metastatic melanoma as part of their
standard of care and specifically for
patients who had also had non CNS
metastasis resected from other sites and
so again we used Oct embedded tissue hne
guided microdissection to isolate
proteins to run on the protein arrays we
also looked at hotspot point mutations
and showed that they were very
consistent between the brain metastasis
and the extracranial disease and
individual patients and at the RNA level
we also saw very very high level of
similarity but actually at the protein
level the striking difference that we
saw was that every single brain
metastases had a higher expression of
activation specific markers in the pi3
kinase pathway compared to the
extracranial metastasis in the same
patient and this actually has been
validated independently by a group in
Germany by immunohistochemistry studies
again strongly implicating the pi3
kinase pathway in brain metastasis now
again those studies were conducted with
OCT bedded frozen tissues and over time
again we've seen a rapid expansion in
the capabilities of multiple
technologies to
work with FFPE specimens which really
opens up large number of specimens for
analysis and so we've actually collected
a cohort of 98 brain metastases from 84
patients we've used these tissues to do
isolation of DNA and RNA the results of
those analyses will actually be
presented at the 2018 AAC our annual
meeting for those who've you are
interested in terms of proteins we've
done some standard IHC markers but again
this we thought was an interesting
opportunity to again use the naina
string digital spatial profiling
platform to characterize signaling
proteins and the immune response in
these clinical specimens and in
particular as Joe mentioned the ability
to use masking so that we could
separately look at the expression of
those markers in tumor cells and in
immune cells was something that again
was very attractive to us in these
highly heterogeneous specimens and so
this slide actually shows our first
pilot experiment this is actually a
brain metastasis that we analyzed from a
patient who had a brain metastasis and
an extra cranial metastasis we selected
now 12 regions of interest in each tumor
to assess spatial heterogeneity the data
was then that we obtained was normalized
to the number of cells in each ROI again
using the digital spatial profiling to
look at our panels of signaling pathway
proteins and what we again did is use
the masking and an example this is shown
down in the lower panel on the Left
where what we can see is we used s 100 B
to recognize the melanoma cells which
are shown in green we then used cd45
which is shown in red to recognize the
immune cells and then we could used a P
to actually count the number of nuclei
and so our initial analyses again wanted
to focus specifically on the status of
signaling pathways in the brain
metastasis and thus in the s 100
positive cells and so down here at the
bottom we see the results for the
signaling proteins in this single
patient where we again were able to
separately measure 12 different regions
of interest in the brain metastasis and
12 different regions of interest in the
extracranial metastasis
measure multiple phospho specific
proteins and as indicated by the arrows
what we saw for multiple markers in the
pi3 kinase pathway so that the
expression of these activation specific
markers was significantly higher in the
brain met from this patient which are
shown as the pink circles compared to
the non CNS metastases which are the
green circles there and so overall this
again sort of identified up regulation
of multiple phospho specific markers in
the pi3 kinase Akt pathway in brain
metastasis and in some ways again this
was a nice confirmation of what we had
seen before in our our PPA based study
but to me really sort of jumped out in
the fact that we were able to accomplish
this with a single FFPE slide the fact
that we were able to assess intramural
heterogeneity which we're still working
on and the fact that we again didn't
have to destroy any tissue so that we
could go on and do other studies on this
same slide and so shown here Joe
mentioned I think quite briefly but we
now are sort of working with manna
string on some pilot studies to again do
the digital spacial profiling but now
not of proteins but actually of RNA
molecules and so again this is being
accomplished on a single FFPE slide
where we're now doing in-situ spatial
analysis of just over a thousand rnas
where again we can use the masking
approach to separately look at the
expression in the tumor cells with the
s100 mask and separately and
independently in the immune cells that
we see in each of these tissue samples
using the cd45 mask and so this is again
a very exciting extension of the
technology that we think will be quite
powerful for our studies and studies of
other investigators moving forward and
so just to summarize the data again it's
really a very exciting time to be
working in oncology as we develop much
more effective therapies and as we
develop really powerful tools to really
sort of develop biomarkers that can be
used to guide the therapy for our
patients and so I hope again I've
explained that the fact that there is
really strong evidence and unk that
oncogenic pathways and tumor cells can
impact the anti tumor response and the
data that I didn't show you there's
actually very
strong data that the immune response
will impact the efficacy of targeted
therapy and so together this data really
strongly supports the rationale for
integrated analysis of both signaling
and immune pathways in our clinical
specimens I think hopefully you've also
appreciated the growing understanding
that we have of the complexity of and
the heterogeneity of both molecular de
Muniz that we can see in tissues both
between different tumors and even within
individual tumors and finally what we
find so exciting is the increasing
capabilities to interrogate molecular to
mewn features on small FFPE clinical
specimens and again as we've
demonstrated again a tremendous amount
of information that can be attained even
for single FFPE slides and I think this
again is providing tremendous potential
and opportunity for new insights new
biomarkers and ultimately new
personalized approaches for our patients
so with that I'd like to thank many of
the people who worked on this project
our collaborators and nana string and
the support that we had for the study
thank you
thank you dr. Michael Davis and dr.
Joseph Beecham that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask the question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
what answers many of your questions is
we have time for let's get started our
first question is for dr. Beecham what
do you see as the potential advantages
of digital spatial profiling
capabilities
thank you very much for the question I
think I think probably Mike Mike and I
actually sort of highlighted very very
similar things in terms of the intrinsic
advantages and I thought of one that we
actually did mention so I want to add
that to the to the list but clearly
being able to have the high multiplexing
you know allows Mike to be ask those
kinds of questions were what are the
signaling pathways linked to
heterogeneous areas of a tumor that's a
question that simply could not be a test
in a quantitative way before we were
able to do the kind of high multiplex
work that that the digital spatial
profiler provides so I think having the
high multiplex capability the unique
capability of being able to mask out
reaches up to her in tumor
micro-environment I think both of us
highlighted that this idea that you can
actually make these measurements and as
you actually haven't utilized any sample
so you get this reusability component
associated with the with the technology
is a huge advantage to be able to go and
be interrogate a sample so we're really
entering a new this is really a new type
of capability inside the microscope or
sort of bringing the power of molecular
profiling into the spatial regime and
that's really the major advance we have
here the one that we didn't mention so
much and I'm just going to highlight
here briefly is
you know microscopy is sort of a
specialized art you got people that know
how to run microscopes adult and I
should highlight this digital space your
profile you don't actually have to be a
microscope at all you really do is you
load the slides into the front of the of
the digital spatial profile you close
the door and then it's off it runs
automatically it's all remotely
controlled you could have a different it
could be being controlled by a
pathologist that's not even in your
building as we collaborate or it could
be you know halfway around the world and
actually be helping you control the
microscope or control the ahta me the
reaches of interest but the key thing is
you don't have to be on microscopy
expert to do this if you're a molecular
profiler and all of a sudden you really
want to become you know essentially
doing state-of-the-art high Plex
microscopy you don't have to learn how
to become a microscopy so all this
instrumentation is is basically
automated so I mean I think that that
captures the strategic features that
both Mike and I work we're trying to
highlight in this talk thank you yeah
yeah and I think I'll just add to it I
mean again as a biologist when we say
that tumors have increased expression of
a particular target versus another based
on homogenous we do always wonder is
this about sort of a specific sub
population of cells that have very high
expression whereas others don't or is
this something global and again really
appreciate with this technology the fact
that you can address this spatially and
actually not just for one marker but as
Joe mentioned really for whole panels of
markers at a time the other thing that
this actually allows us to do is
actually look at the interactions
between different markers between
different signaling pathways that I
think is really going to provide us with
much better granularity about our
understanding about the molecular
biology about the immunology and about
the heterogeneity of cancer
thank you our next question is for dr.
David you talk about the challenges
surrounding maximizing analysis of small
FFPE sections how does it platform like
dsb impact research strategies and your
everyday practices in the lab yeah
that's a it's a great question and again
I think one of the most interesting
aspects of the DSP platform you know
it's one of the things that in the
studies we presented we really were sort
of highlighting again looking at
heterogeneity of tumor cells again first
in regions with Inter terminal
heterogeneity and then with the brain
metastasis in tumors where we had a high
inter mixing of different cell
populations you know one of the
practical applications of this is
actually going to be is actually using
samples or biopsies where we actually
have a lot of necrosis and being able to
actually again not let those parts of
the tissue sort of contaminate your
analysis to be able to go in and
spatially pick out sort of regions of
viable tissue is another I think very
practical advantage of this approach I
think overall again what we're really
encouraged by is we as in the field of
melanoma have found DNA based predictors
of outcomes RNA based predictors of
outcomes and protein based predictors of
outcomes as I was illustrating at the
end the fact that we're you know
potentially looking at a platform where
you may be able to get DNA RNA and
protein based data really all at one
time is really quite intriguing
and I think you know in addition to
really sort of having potential
applications and research I think
ultimately I could have real
implications for you know clinical and
diagnostic testing and and hopefully for
guiding patient care
thank you for that answer our next
question is for dr. Davis how can the
DSP platform help to develop tools that
can be used to select patients that will
benefit from immunotherapy yeah so this
is obviously a very pressing question
not only in melanoma but in multiple
fields and again this is an area where
we've seen the development of both DNA
and RNA based biomarkers as well as some
a monistic chemical stains and again I
think that there's going to be an
opportunity to be able to assess these
things at the same time or to be able to
access multiple different parameters
again using a very small amount of FFPE
tissue I think the other part that what
we're going to see the ability to do is
again many types of approaches
particularly RNA based approaches have
been homogenous which really again end
up being significantly influenced by
what your relative proportion of tumor
cells and immune cells are I think where
there's a real opportunity here is to be
able to separately look to say are there
again markers in the tumor cells that
tell us about will patients respond or
not or separately
are there markers in those immune cells
and again one of the things that we're
particularly excited about is the
ability to look at the status of
signaling pathways not only in tumor
cells but at their status in the immune
cells as predictors of outcomes and our
hope is is that again doing those types
of analyses would not only identify
biomarkers that can predict which
patients will or won't respond but
hopefully we'll also provide biological
insights that explain why resistance
happens and again provides rationale
strategies to overcome them
thank you for that answer it looks like
we have time for one more question our
last question is for dr. David there is
a growing number of RNA based diagnostic
tests what are the advantages and
disadvantages of doing testing with
spatial resolution so great I think that
again sort of a very important question
again I think that one of the things
that's a real advantage of what we've
sort of described here so far is the
ability to do this with a single FFPE
slide the ability to know what it is
you're profiling and to do that quite
carefully I think that you know in terms
of disadvantages the part that we're
going to be moving forward with is
needing to validate those types of that
we're going to need to validate this
moving forward as a new way to look at
least when we talk about things like RNA
signatures certainly again I think in
terms of looking at protein markers like
cd8 in cd8 positive cell infiltrates or
PDL one expression those are going to
convert very easily but I think that
again this is a very powerful approach
that we're going to be able to use
moving forward
I'd like to make one more comment there
so I am sitting here looking at the last
slide here and I wanted to call out
thanks to one other person that actually
I see on your acknowledgments there Mike
could you don't mind
you know both Mike and I work very
closely with AG uh the professor down
there named Gordon Mills and I just when
I highlight and thank Gordon actually
Gordon and I are sort of co-inventors of
this particular microscope and I just
want to sort of highlight and thank
Gordon died here publicly so that no
it's been a really fun project and
that's and working with Mike it's been a
close relationship between all the
protein detection Singh and the whole
team at MD Anderson is just exceptional
and it's been fun Co developing this
technology together sort of technology
again commercial technology developing
company with the best medical center in
the world and I think I think together
we come up with a pretty nice tool
that's going to help not patient care in
the long term
and it's been a pleasure to again work
on this and again particularly to work
with people are so invested again in
generating a project that will really
help patients and again I think this is
a win-win for everyone
I would like to once again thank dr.
Michael Davis and dr. Joseph Beecham for
their presentation I would also like to
thank nano string technologies for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018 you'll receive an
email from Lavery's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon
goodbye